[Musique]
bravo monsieur le terrain ça je suis
très honorée que ce soit toi qui me
remettent ccr ce soir merci merci je ne
vais pas cacher que j'ai longtemps rêvé
de ça de ce moment là avec mes potes on
s'entraîne à faire des discours avec nos
télécommandes et là c'est vrai et je me
dis que pour quoi et en même temps je me
dis pourquoi pas merci merci à tous ceux
qui ont voté pour moi
merci à mme mounia meddour de m'avoir
offert son rôle de m'avoir faire ta vie
de m'avoir offert ce neige marque qui
veut dire l'étoile où tu es mon étoile
jeter mia merci merci à tous nos
producteurs parce que vous êtes des
hommes et vous avez sûrement vu que nous
vous avez porté
on l'a fait ensemble et vous êtes là
xavier patrick belkacem merci merci
hassan guerrar de nous suivre depuis le
début merci mes agents grégory emmanuel
merci à ma mère maman je je je suis que
devant ta télé etc est en train de
pleurer je t'aime maman merci d'avoir de
m'avoir faire ta vie merci papa parce
que c'est toi qui m'a appris le cinéma
c'est toi qui m'as donné second merci
papa merci à mon frère parce que sinon
il va être jaloux donc facile et je veux
juste partager avec vous quelques mots
d'une grande révolutionnaire de notre
monde
djamila bouhired qui nous dit il vous
appartient vous les artistes qui mettait
de la lumière dans l'obscurité de notre
quotidien
il vous appartient vous tous de dessiner
votre avenir et de donner corps à vos
rêves
ne les laissez pas pervertir la noblesse
de votre combat ne les laissez pas voler
votre victoire
merci
[Applaudissements]